big night for the clark county school
district superintendent dr jesus jarrah
returning to his seat during tonight's
regular board meeting this after a
contentious couple of months that began
with trustees firing him then going back
on that decision now parents teachers
and students say they just want to focus
on the future sasha loftis joining us
live tonight with more on ccsd sasha
brian this was actually one of the
calmest meetings we've been to in a
while those we spoke with really hope
that district leaders can leave the
chaos of the last few months behind them
and move forward
this last couple weeks there's been just
chaos after months of contention the
message from parents students and
teachers is clear we're here to move
forward we're here to help these
children many are ready to move on as dr
jesus jarrah made his first appearance
at thursday's board meeting we're moving
forward since trustees voted to fire him
then rescinded that decision weeks later
it is somewhat frustrating sam huang
says as a student he's seen serious
issues across the district and believes
these arguments are anything but
productive so he's asking those in
charge to do things differently this
time but to ask well what can we do
better what are we not doing right now 8
news now obtained this signed agreement
between dr jarrah and several ccsd
trustees which shed light on past issues
and laid out a plan to communicate and
cooperate moving forward not just to
listen but to actively listen it may be
a step in the right direction but sam
hopes these leaders follow through and
put kids first for a better brighter
future what we can get done together is
beyond anything that i believe that we
are doing right now
now after that agreement was signed
trustee daniel ford actually said she
was excluded from the meeting discussing
it for reportedly quote violating
confidentiality we have a look at that
full agreement and her full statement on
our website right now eight news now dot
com reporting live tonight sasha loftis
live local now